The breaking news is out of Alabama.
The mayor of Selma says there
is, quote, significant damage
from a tornado.
There are several southern state
that are currently under tornado
Let's bring in Jennifer Gray.
So what's going on right now?
Guys, we have these fast moving
and they are very powerful curre
moving through the southeast.
You can see this tornado
watch that we have through the a
and early evening hours.
And here's
the line of showers and storms
that are pushing through Alabama
into Georgia and across the sout
So this tornado that impacted Se
basically an hour ago,
these storms are now on the move
So Selma is past the danger zone
We should stay.
But these storms are still very
and potentially tornado producin
You can see that
hot pink box right there.
That's a tornado warning.
That is from the same storm
that impacted Selma.
An hour ago.
So these are very dangerous
if you live in this area.
Definitely get to your safe zone
right now
and be weather aware
as we go through
throughout the afternoon.
These are going to impact
some big cities.
Atlanta, possibly
during the rush hour, guys,
we could see these line of showe
and storms push through.
You can see
we have a tornado warning there
just on the west side of Macon a
So this is a very dire situation
Here's the warning area
that we're looking at for this a
with the greatest potential
for tornadoes,
very strong winds and large hail
That does
include Montgomery, even Atlanta
throughout the day today.
So as we put these
storms in motion,
you can see heading through Atla
this afternoon, three
to five, even 6:00,
and then it pushes through the e
by six 30.
These storms are still going
to be very powerful.
And then finally dying down
as they make their way off the c
by the time we get into the late
evening hours through the overni
So, guys, the next couple of hou
really crucial with these storms
A very powerful tornado producin
We've got breaking news out of A
Emergency response teams
are there
providing assistance in Selma
after a tornado caused significa
to the city.
A several buildings have been da
and some injuries have been repo
there due to the severe weather.
In Decatur, Alabama,
you can see crews here
trying to clean up.
Look at this, a semi
turned on to its side in the sto
Let's discuss now with the direc
of field operations
for Alabama Emergency Management
Ricky Adams.
Mr. Adams, thank you for your ti
Let me start with life and any i
Can you tell me about casualties
potentially
that have come in reports
that you're receiving
Well,
we are receiving some reports
from across the state,
several different tornado sighti
but no reports of fatalities
at this time.
However, the counties and the st
are still assessing the damage
and the weather service is on sc
And Selma looking at that damage
Where is it worst
Well, it's a relative statement,
but it is worse than the Selma a
in the western parts of the stat
right now.
But again, it's still early
and we're still assessing.
Yeah, I know.
You're just your crews across th
and local fire rescue.
They're getting to these places.
But what can you tell us about
what is in Selma
and the damage reports
that you're hearing?
Well, the damage reports
we have thus far from the county
structural damage,
trees, downed power lines down.
And the area is very difficult t
due to debris.
So the information
is going to be a little slow com
but they are working to house to
an area,
the area
looking for people who may be tr
and those who are injured.
So they're going house to house
And you're saying that
because of these downed trees,
it's going to take some time
to get to
these people who are making call
is that right?
Yes.
It just slows the process down
as they try to navigate the debr
and downed trees.
How crucial is it to get to
some of these areas
before the sun goes down, before
things go dark,
regardless of the hour
today is important to get to tho
as quickly as we can.
We're in life safety mode.
And that's
the purpose
is to try to find
as many people as we can.
Is the threat over?
No, the threat is not over
for the state of Alabama.
In fact,
that same weather system
is still moving
through the central part of the
And still moving east.
So it is
still a very significant weather
for us.
All right, Ricky Adams,
thank you for your time
and thank you for what you're do
Thank you very much.